welcome to the smite God revealed
forgive God of Earth
in smite gab pummels his opponents as a
guardian
the hold of the rumble from the deep for
it is the bellow of rock and stone a
Titan of immortal ages has awoken from
fitful slumber to crush all who tread
upon his realm a lumbering giant patient
deliberate unmovable
he is gab God of Earth when a mortals
heart is weighed in the halls of Ma'at
gabot sits among the gods in judgment
those burdened with guilt and regret are
claimed by gab and dragged through the
earthen crust to the underworld
hearts free of such heaviness are taught
words of power and ascend to the sky ah
the sky it is but the one thing gab
longs for in his eye
she is glorious sapphire an unreachable
object but it was not always so once the
earth and sky were as one gab and newt
goddess of the sky locked in a lover's
embrace raw deemed their union unfit and
sent shu god of wind between them in his
rage gabe thundered and broke the earth
but for naught newt was now forever out
of reach though his desire has not
weathered with the ages gab has rested
peacefully for time memorial nurturing
mankind through bountiful harvest and
stable ground for pyramids and palaces
it is the clash of gods upon his surface
that stirs him he has risen to war
though his motives are unclear does he
fight to prevent the destruction of his
realm or will he seize the chance to
shatter the wind and reunite the earth
and sky whatever the outcome the earth
will always remain
gebbs passive is called hard as rock
crits only do a percentage of damage to
gab rather than the normal plus 100% his
first ability is called roll out Gabe
turns into a massive rolling earth
damaging and slowing enemies he
encounters stopping at the first God he
hits he increases speed as he travels
and his damage scales once at his top
speed
Gabe becomes CC immune and will also
knock back enemy God's his second
ability is called shockwave Gabe creates
a shockwave causing damage and knock up
to all enemies enemies closer to Gabe
take full damage enemies at the furthest
edge take less
Gabe's third ability is called stone
shield Gabe targets himself or an ally
to put a shield around the shield blocks
all damage and knock-back effects and
lasts until it's time expires or takes
enough damage to be destroyed the shield
also cleanses any CC when applied Gabe's
ultimate is called Cataclysm Gabe pulls
apart the earth ax dealing magical
damage to all enemy gods based on a
percent of their current health and
stunning them
in this first fight gebben Apollo come
in from the jungle in the sheet and roll
out gebbs knock back fails the spender
takes off with Apollo cleansing his ally
with shield gabe takes the kill with a
deadly shockwave in the second fight get
places stone shield on himself as he
dives the phoenix knocking up a mousse
and calm and sun wukong with shockwave
gab gets an assist from mousse and as he
takes down Wukong in this final fight
Gavin as allies push the middle Phoenix
stunning all nearby enemies with
Cataclysm Gabe continues with a
shockwave at amis and have an ill
executed blink sees the god of these
pummeled
as the god of earth gag controls the
terrain around him to shield his allies
and refuse enemies starting him off with
shockwave is an excellent idea for its
wave clear and knock up potential next
picking up stone shield can aid gebbs
laning partner and counter any crowd
control threats from there the priority
shift to Cataclysm stone shield
shockwave rollout hell anims and cab
make their golden debut also introduced
in this patch is the addition of a brand
new arena map matches will randomly
rotate between the traditional arena map
and the newly updated nighttime arena
the traditional Maps the gameplay rules
will remain the same while in the newly
updated map the manticore will spawn
after every 10 player kills on a side if
your side can escort the manticore
through the other teams portal you gain
extra points
thanks for watching the smite God reveal
for Gabe god of Earth